hey David what do white supremacists
extremists and hate groups expect Trump
to actually do for them this is a really
interesting question because we've seen
the rise of hate incidents under Donald
Trump we've seen the rise of
anti-semitism white supremacy political
violence from the right and Trump has
sort of catalyzed and coalesced these
hate groups and extremists in a way that
no recent president or presidential
candidate with any serious chance of
winning has been able to do but there's
a really kind of obvious question in
there which is even if they are
supporting Trump even if they are
activated by Trump Trump is not going to
just start passing legislation that
directly excites them in a way that we
might say that is white supremacists law
although maybe some people in the
audience disagree so why is it that
they're supporting him so fervently and
what do they think he's going to do you
only have to go back and see what
they've said when I interviewed white
nationalist Richard Spencer on the
program it's now been a couple of years
interviews on YouTube I encourage you to
check it out oh we had this discussion
and what Richard Spencer said and I'm
paraphrasing here was more or less we
understand the limits of what a
president might be expected to do we
understand that Trump's son-in-law and
daughter by conversion and grandkids are
Jewish and he's not going to literally
become the public anti-semite that they
might like but they see it as the
closest thing that they've had and they
see more sort of systemically that the
environment that Donald Trump has
created created during the campaign has
created as president is advantageous to
them in that more of their ideas are if
not endorsed by Donald Trump at least
sort of implicitly allowed case in point
when you had the Charlottesville fiasco
you had Donald Trump sort of taking this
I don't know if coy is the right word
I would call it more of a disgusting
point of view but if saying listen there
were very fine people on both sides both
a meaningless comment but at the same
time a big sort of welcome to the idea
that merely because there were
anti-semites and white supremacists and
people shouting the Jews will not
replace us or whatever the phrase was
Trump is still not unilaterally
condemning them so I don't think that
it's actually about what do the
extremists expect Trump to do in terms
of legislation it's more the idea that
Trump has made it clear by doing
everything from saying I'll pay the
legal fees of people who get violent
against protesters at rallies to
everything else that we've seen for them
the environment is one where their ideas
are not immediately ostracized in the
way that they they may have previously
been and we're seeing it in the numbers
the anti-defamation league counted
almost 1,200 incidents of extremist
propaganda hate group propaganda in 2018
that's up more than 50% from 2017 which
was of course up from 2016 and college
campuses are a big target but also even
off campus we're seeing a huge increase
in these incidents the alt-right is also
using all sorts of different propaganda
massive methods to promote their message
it's not just internet they're doing
much more in person stuff because
they're emboldened so once again it's
not about Trump's going to pass a law
saying Jews need to wear a yellow star
or whatever right I mean we're not even
that that that's not what we're talking
about we're talking about a general
environment where these individuals feel
as though at least some degree their
ideas have been mainstreamed in a way
that they haven't previously seen and
Donald Trump has at least shown sort of
an indifference to some of this stuff
and we we see that in the statements
that he's made after particular
incidents have taken place we have a
great bonus show for you today although
the stories on the bonus show or not
delightful stories a man who ran a red
light and killed a mother of two has
been sentenced to 30 days in jail and
there are many people who are furious
about the sentence I want to talk a
little bit about the Andrew yang
strategy
for some people are saying he's gaming
the system to get into the 2020 debates
I think he's just playing the game as
designed by the rules and we'll also
talk about a credit card debt crisis
that is growing in the United States all
of those stories and more on the bonus
show if you're not a member please
become a member
ww join pakman.com not only will you be
supporting the program which is great if
if you believe that independent
progressive media deserves support but
you'll get instant access to the bonus
show and I look forward to speaking to
you then